c'est blanche et bonsoir bien heureux
d'être là on est tu veux nous accueillir
comme vous les autres chefs dans votre
plateforme le mot indépendance
n'apparaît pas si vous n'en parlez pas
qui va en parler quelques petites choses
là-dessus dans un premier temps depuis
la dernière élection fédérale biopôle eu
de changement à l'assemblée nationale du
québec l'environnement dans lequel
l'indépendance serait mise de l'avant
par une démarche vers un référendum sur
la souveraineté n'a pas du tout changé
par contre qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est que pendant 2 de façon assez
systématique
on a obtenu ou contribué à obtenir des
gains pour le québec aller chercher plus
de pouvoir protéger une pouvoir affirmer
que nous sommes maîtres le français de
l'avant faire reconnaître la nation
québécoise et tous ces éléments mis
ensemble font en sorte que d'une nation
ne peut que développer le goût d'un peu
plus de ça jusqu'au moment où un vin qui
appartiendront aux québécois c'est pas à
moi de trancher sur le moment et c'est
pas à toi ou à l'étranger sur le moment
mais quand les québécois vont sentir que
ça devienne fans ont sorti un bel élan
mais n'est ce pas la preuve que le
fédéralisme ne fonctionne non parce que
le fédéralisme c'est essayer tout le
temps d'aller chercher des pouvoirs
essayez tout le temps de protéger des
pouvoirs la souveraineté c'est avoir
d'emblée l'ancien et des pouvoirs je
pense par contre que l'aboutissement
naturel du nationalisme dans bien des
cas c'est en effet l'appropriation de
tous les attributs de souris en fondant
le québécois 1990 le sencha avait claqué
la porte grenoble journée puis à belize
et speed rail marche pas foule refaire
et à ce moment là il ya développé ce
front souverainiste avoir et plusieurs
voies l'étonnement s'est pas développé
un front caquistes à ottawa j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté avec ce non pas
parce que je manque de sympathie pour un
certain nombre de positions de la
coalition bois québec mais on a vu dans
les derniers jours les demandes du
gouvernement du québec à ottawa ça c'est
sorti bien après certains des positions
historiques du blog d'ailleurs qui sont
antérieurs à l'existence même de la
coalition mire québec et la plupart des
positions qu'on met de l'avant
ces dépositions qui sont appuyés sur des
votes unanimes de l'assemblée nationale
donc ça inclut québec solidaire le parti
québécois et le parti libéral et bien
sûr la coalition avenir québec le fait
que deux formations politiques soient
résolument nationaliste décomplexée
tannés de se faire traiter de reste si
son ensemble de choses en commun sur la
vision économique du québec veut pas
dire qu'un s'inspire de l'autre veut
dire qu'ils partent d'une place
relativement comparables et s'en vont
dans une même direction la différence
c'est que nous on va aller au bout de
l'exercice et qu'un jour le québec soit
souvent alors je reviens à ma première
question si vous voulez aller au bout
l'exercice mais que vous n'en parlez pas
de ce bout d'exercice est à dire
l'indépendance qui va en parler nous
dirait très humblement ceci dans la
dernière année mais si je m'étais mis à
parler d'indépendance une fois par
semaine vous auriez peut-être été parmi
les premières à 10m jeu de l'enchère est
ce que c'est vraiment en parler
d'indépendance en pleine pandémie donc
il ya eu une pandémie ça peut bouger à
québec je les dis je le répète s'il n'y
avait pas l'ange de souveraineté du
québec je ne serais pas là où je suis
maintenant les premiers du québec
françois legault accuse le npd et les
libéraux des trousses centralisateur
d'après vous ce qu'il donne c'est un
petit coup de pouce aux conservateurs
devenu auto vous savez il ya à peu près
trois semaines un mois quand monsieur
trudeau et monsieur legault par hasard
presque habillés pareils avait annoncé
l'entente sur les garderies là on
parlait d'une brume ans drôle de mot
entre monsieur trudeau et monsieur
legault et l'oeil quelques jours
monsieur o'toole a pris des positions
certaines des positions qui peuvent
plaire aux québécois et il en était
rendu dans une brume ans entre monsieur
otto les monsieur legault moi j'ai siégé
avec monsieur legault il ya plusieurs
années à l'assemblée nationale du québec
mais je pense qu'on a des convergences
d'idées beaucoup plus que des
convergences de romantisme et si les
idées que l'assemblée nationale du
québec porte et que le bloc québécois
portes vont dans une même direction ça
donne au québec un poids très très
considérable à ottawa et à bien des
égards c'est aussi son de travail en
même temps quand monsieur le groupe
accuse donc monsieur trudeau est mal le
parti libéral est en fait d'aider trop
centralisateur il sans le dire que ce ne
sont pas des bons amis pour le québec ce
serait qu'il meilleur ami pour le québec
et pour vous un petit transigeait à
taiwan ont sans équivoque le meilleur
ami pour le québec c'est le bloc
québécois
que les canadiens se choisissent le
gouvernement qui le voudront les
québécois ont de nouveau cette fois-ci
l'option d'éviter que ce soit un
gouvernement majoritaire qui détruirait
détruire et pardon
un nombre considérable des acquis des
deux dernières années tout le monde a
reconnu
l'influencent puis je ne nous revendique
pas démérité exclusif la mêle influences
qu'on a eue sur la politique québécoise
sur la politique canadienne au bénéfice
du québec depuis un an et demi deux ans
des compromis qui n'aurait jamais existé
sans la présence du bloc québécois il ya
un risque important prenez l'exemple de
glyphosate parce qu'il vient facilement
ils ont dit écoutez on va suspendre la
décision sur les glyphes ozap mais
jusqu'en 2022 si les libéraux sont
majoritaires ils bien le bonsoir on va
ramener la hausse des seuils de befoza
c'est gros comme intrigue en faisant
toute votre liste de genk sont très
nombreux dans votre programme les
agriculteurs les fonds de retraite
l'assurance emploi et tout ça vous fait
par le biais même un peu le bilan d'un
gouvernement libéral minoritaire
alors je demande encore une fois le
meilleur ami pour vous est ce qu'un
gouvernement minoritaire conservateur
ça vous inscrire pour moi j'ai la
prétention que qui que ce soit qui soit
au gouvernement si c'est un gouvernement
minoritaire on continuera à faire des
gains pour le québec et je dirais que
deux types de
revendications de mérite qu'on se gagne
au sud de trucs qui viennent carrément
nous la protection de l'ue minium ça
vient nous autres la protection sur les
fonds de pension comme créancier
prioritaire ça vienne nous organisons si
vraiment nous autres il ya des choses où
on était essentielle pour que les
libéraux y arrive la loi de mise en
oeuvre de leur propre budget n'aurait
pas été adopté sans le soutien du bloc
le premier discours du trône répond été
adopté sans le soutien du bloc la loi
c-10 que malheureusement le sénat se
permet de bloquer n'aurait pas été
adopté et n'ont même pas dans sa forme
qui protège le français la nouveauté
sans le rôle du bloc des fois ci en
collaboration parce qu'on est un parti
qui dit encore si c'est bon pour le
québec on est pour 6 est mauvais on est
content et on essaie d'améliorer sa
table pour que ça serve le québec mais
monsieur blanchet pour poursuivre sur
cette lancée qui serait meilleur pour
les intérêts du québec un gouvernement
minoritaire rouge ou un gouvernement
minoritaire bleus auraient l'impression
de mal gérer des affaires canadien
vous n'avez pas d'avis sur les
programmes sur les propositions c'est
pour servir le québec je suis prêt à
travailler avec n'importe qui c'est ce
qui est un homme bon j'aurai j'ai de la
misère avec ceux qui font un fonds de
commerce de mépriser les québécois mais
outre sa je pense qu'on a réussi à
collaborer parfois avec les libéraux qui
enrichira collaborer parfois avec les
conservateurs je ne suis pas très
sensible aux chants des sirènes des
conservateurs en matière de transferts
en santé 60 milliards c'est sur 10 ans
et 6 % de hausse par année et si ce que
les premiers ministres ont déjà dénoncé
en disant c'est pas assez longue et il
faut voir il faut aller au fond des
vraies affaires enlevée 6 milliards au
québec sur les garderies pour le donner
à moscou est fort ce qui nuit
expressément au québec c'est un problème
refuser la transition énergétique ça
reste un problème à être pro choix dans
un parti qui n'est pas pro choix c'est
un problème dire aux médecins qui seront
obligés sauf problème être content et
je capable
j'ai mieux fait des propositions
ambitieuses legault vous a bien dit a
bien vu quand même aux québécois mais il
ya deux parti centralisateur regardez
écoutez bien ce qu'ils ont à dire ses
chefs et ses il a ouvert la voie il a
ouvert la porte il est dit baillet deux
parties est vous qui allez conservateur
donc il était que je le reconnaît
facilement les conservateurs ont une
approche moins centralisatrice que les
libéraux et le npd est ce que ça veut
dire que les conservateurs servirait
mieux le québec sur des éléments
fondamentaux de l'économie ou de
l'identité mais quoi je n'y crois pas
les conservateurs sont pas en faveur des
transferts en santé demandée ils sont
pas en faveur du transfert sur les
garderies qui était proposé son poids en
faveur de l'augmentation de l'aide aux
aînés qu'on a fait et qui reste
absolument fondamental ils sont pas en
faveur de permettre au québec de
procéder à sa transition économique et
énergétique parce qu'ils veulent
continuer à soutenir d'autres de l'ouest
donc il reste des différences majeures
entre l'ain entre l'original et la copie
sur les éléments programme du bloc
québécois ben je suppose que les
québécois pourraient s'intéresser à
l'origine iliad il ya des choses en
commun comme vous ils sont en faveur du
troisième ligne
arrive
que je n'étais pas faudra s'entendre oui
mais là je pose la question à vous feng
six stations très courtes très joli tous
conviennent de l'urgence climatique
puis il faut être cohérent
l'environnement doit être le critère
d'analysé de tous nos projets à partir
de maintenant tu blanchet quel est le
potentiel écologique du troisième lien
je n'ai pas encore compris c'est j'avais
rappelé que très très souple cherchant
vous avez à vous ils avaient trait au
public la décision puis on va traverser
sera d'un coup la décision relève de
québec l'euro 10 fédéral et de
transférer les sommes que demande québec
dans les demandes tout récent du premier
ministre hugo c'est transfert en bloc de
toutes les sommes relatives aux
infrastructures québec
juridiction québécoise après ça
québec irresponsable des évaluations
environnementales il responsable des
consultations publiques et responsable
d'obtenir l'acceptabilité sociale il est
responsable de faire en sorte que le
projet soit le plus écologique possible
qu'est ce que j'ai dis qu'est-ce que je
redis ce soir ça se peut ça s'peut le
potentiel est là mais c'est à québec de
faire mon travail mon travail est de
protéger les juridictions de l'assemblée
nationale du québec qui à l'intérieur
c'est des accords puisque en annonçant
qu'ils voudront parce que c'est un peu
normal mon travail n'est pas demain
gérer mais je sais que ça peut être fait
de façon
passablement ou beaucoup plus écologique
décision qu'il ne relèvera pas de moi
vous continuez à dire monsieur blanchet
qu'un potentiel
écologique passe au pied pour des
raisons économiques sociales qu'on
veuille faire un tunnel très bien mais
de dire que c'est un potentiel
écologique ce que vous reconnaissez que
vous êtes allé un peu trop loin extra
fort en café un peu je ne crois pas je
vais vous donner deux exemples dans les
jours qui ont suivi j'étais
imprégné par saguenay ont été l'objet
d'un rapport de pêches et océans canada
qui disent il faut pas qu'il y ait un
bateau de plus qui parle sur le saguenay
condamnant le saguenay-lac-saint-jean à
tout développement économique terminé la
principale voie pour sortir c'est sûr
pour l'instant tellement que la mairesse
de saint denis disait que des
entreprises qui nous disent on va s'en
aller ailleurs
quand j'étais ministre l'environnement à
l'époque quoi qu'en dise monsieur
guilbeault je disais ce que je dis
encore aujourd'hui on ne doit pour
opposer le développe main et
l'environnement on doit concilier le
développement l'environnement et dans le
contexte actuel les dizaines de
milliards qu'on coule dans le pétrole de
l'ouest doivent être investis dans un
énorme chantier de transition écologique
de transition économique qui vaut créer
plus de richesses qui vont ouvrir des
marchés par l'innovation plutôt que
d'être ceux qui traînent la patte au
niveau environnemental ont continué à
soutenir en disant le contraire le
pétrole de l'ouest je compte vous disiez
ça passe ça m'amène à l'autre question
monsieur blanche on a l'impression
vous avez parlé de votre passage comme
inès de l'environnement quant au québec
on veut que ça pollue moins cimenterie
magnus forage anticosti vous avez envie
voir ce que du pétrole gnl vous êtes on
va attendre le bac mais je pas contre
mais on va attendre le bas quand c'est à
l'extérieur du québec c'est le pétrole
sale [ __ ] au québec les projets prover
ils sont acceptables
j'adore tellement les questions d'abord
anticosti a dit que si la décision d'y
aller d'y aller n'était pas la mienne
mon travail était doit être le
protecteur et j'avais dit à l'époque je
serai dans les bottes des compagnies
pour que ce soit fait le mieux possible
j'ai toujours été convaincu comme je l
ai dit de nombreuses fois depuis que ça
pouvait pas être rentable que la
restauration environnementale par la
suite n'était pas possible et comme de
fait il s'est jamais rien passé avec ça
mon travail il me donnait pas le pouvoir
de dire à la premier ministre vous irez
pas là il me donne une certaine autorité
morale pour essayer de mettre des
paramètres de la protection dans le
dossier de par daniel lio trois semaines
un mois j'étais au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean je suis allé
voir une entreprise se développe et du
charbon biologique du bio charbon le bio
charbon et carboneutre mon entente avec
mc innis à l'époque toute la partie on
n'a pas respecté notre parole on nous
demandait des centaines de millions pour
ça rien à voir avec moi la partie
environnementale de négocier une entente
que 40% de la production énergétique
viennent de biomasse forestière
résiduelle locales ce qui en aurait fait
s'il avait respecté leur parole la
cimenterie qu'on continue à utiliser la
plus écologique au monde quoi qu'en dise
monsieur guilbeault dont le score
environnementale et pas très
impressionnants non plus
mais pas répondu sur gnl si ce même
projet l'avait été dans l'ouest 0e les
mêmes réponses en disant on va attendre
le bac on peut pas être contre dès le
début c'est le deux poids deux mesures
j'essaye de charge il invite humblement
à consulter les bulletins de nouvelles
de deux il ya quelques semaines où j'ai
dit gnl n'ont jamais une acceptabilité
sociale gnl n'a jamais eu de financement
gnl n'ont jamais eu de clients c'est
vrai depuis le début et j'avais dit à ce
moment là c'est terminé avant même que
ce soit tiré la plogue si j'avais
terminé gnl les gens se sont fait mener
en bateau la région du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean au droit à un
autre type de développement économique
beaucoup plus porteurs et durables
trente secondes monsieur blanchet
pénurie de main d'oeuvre vous voyagez au
québec c'est en campagne les gens
doivent vous parlez de sow les
commerçants les restaurants tout le
monde tout le temps qu on fait quoi plus
d'une maigreur qu'est ce qu'on fait il
ya plusieurs solutions possibles au
problème de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
dont je dis exactement comme vous
partout en outre nos propositions sont
déjà sortis à cet égard le d'ailleurs il
ya plusieurs pistes de solutions d'abord
la pcr eux était un remède à un mal qui
à bien des égards n'existe plus c'est à
dire que ça servait à donner un pouvoir
d'achat nécessaire à des gens qui ne
pouvaient pas faire le travail qu'ils
avaient auparavant à partir du moment où
tout ce monde-là peut retourner au
travail la pcr n'est plus une mesure
nécessaire sauf en culture ou c'est très
très longue revenir au travail c'est une
position que je défends je demande pas
l'abolition je demande la suspension
parce qu'une quatrième vague pourrait
demander qu'on réactive le programme les
incitatifs à garder les jeunes retraités
sur le marché du travail plus longtemps
c'est important il faut travailler sur
les esthètes estime élire des sauces
août jusqu'aux quais de super proton
supplément de revenu garanti fini la
seule immigration plus ou moins est ce
que vous croyez que c'est une jeune et
papa du nombre des migrants je n'ai
jamais eu peur du nombre des migrants
qu'on accueille le nombre des migrants
qu'on accueille est tributaire de notre
capacité et de nos efforts pour les
intégrer notre première responsabilité
c'est de leur donner le principal outil
pour s'intégrer la maîtrise du français
parlé de la quatrième vague on voit que
québec impose la vaccination obligatoire
aux travailleurs de la santé le
gouvernement fédéral lui veulent imposer
aux fonctionnaires fédéraux cette
vaccination obligatoire pourquoi vous
opposez à ça qu'on est pas rendue à ma
première dénonciation là-dessus était
due au fait que monsieur trudeau vous
est escamoté sa décision d'élections
précipitées derrière un coup d'éclat qui
était de dire on va obliger la
vaccination de tous les travailleurs
fédéraux se faisant d'emblée il rentrait
dans la juridiction du québec et de
toutes les provinces parce que la santé
publique est une juridiction des
provinces et du québec en ce2 sur ses
propres fonctionnaires supérieurs avait
dit y en a qui voudront pas il y en a
qui pour bon port l'alternative c'est le
test à l'entrée il y avait des manières
de le faire qui correspondait aux
recommandations de l'appareil public
fédéral mais monsieur trudeau voulait un
coup d'éclat de démarrage sur lequel
vient 6 beaucoup moins vous ai dit tout
à l'heure à eau mais au moins dans les
transports on va le maintenir mais plus
beaucoup sur la fonction publique qu'est
ce que québec a fait dans sage de
résultats au moins dans le système de
santé on va s'il s'en tenir à ça on
verra plus tard mais dans le système de
santé c'est la moindre des choses qui en
mon âme et conscience je disais que
c'est très raisonnable que les gens du
système de santé soient vaccinés donc
vous dites vous n'avez pas aimé la
manière dont ça a été fait mais vous
n'êtes pas content la vaccination
obligatoire je ne suis pas favorable et
ça c'est un peu
une incertitude récente des choix de
monsieur trudeau il ya des gens qui
craignent
qu'ils craignent la vaccination attendre
à mon avis sans l'ombre d'un doute tiens
il faut les informer le mot éduqué il me
semble un peu condescendant mais il faut
les informer il y en a qui vont
continuer à être réfractaire à ça mais
la bonne manière de le faire c'est pas
de dire vous êtes des franches et c'est
pas de dire je ne reculerai jamais puis
s'était pas de commencer la campagne
électorale en dix ans joue à toulouse
obligé une façon quand tu es chef d'état
avec la responsabilité d'être
rassembleur d'avoir une approche plus
pédagogique on approche de corps une
fois de coups d'éclat pour rallier un
électorat pour approche faut aller plus
loin serait monsieur autour de cette
position mais est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ça peut braquer les
gens est ce que ça peut être une cause
qui braquent en fait les gens qui sont
encore hésitants qui sont récalcitrants
l'obligation ce que je crains c'est ce
que je crains ce l'asie que ça nous je
ne me rapproche pas de la position de
monsieur tout le monde a eu des votes
avec les conservateurs à deux noms
reprise puis des fois c'est à notre
initiative il faut souhaiter à la la
c'est le charme d'un parlement
minoritaire
suivant avec les formations politiques
et tu réussi à construire des consensus
comme on l'a vu au début du mandat avant
que ça devienne plus partisan vers la
fin du monde il brouille mind en inde en
une chose que j'ai découvert cette
semaine avait reconnu la contribution du
bloc québécois au programme de début de
pandémie il avait même fait une liste de
soap il disait on est ouvert à bout
recommandations on ne doit être possible
est ce que vous seriez en faveur de
sanctions quand ils font de france
fonctionnaires fédéraux qui refuseraient
c'est dans l'ordre que je trouve que
c'est délicat encore une fois j'ai pas
l'impression que de dire je vais vous
sanctionner pour quelque chose
d'impossible
parce que ses propres fonctionnaires à
monsieur trudeau disent écoutez c'est
pas sûr qu'on recommande aussi que des
gens qui peuvent penser que des gens qui
veulent penser que des alternatives
possibles pour arriver là et au
détriment des recommandations de ses
propres experts monsieur trudeau en
rajoute une couche en disant je vais
vous sanctionner alors qu'il ne sait
même pas comment il pourrait procéder le
chef libéral justin trudeau il promet
aussi des milliards en santé pour les ch
et celle des mais il veut imposer des
normes nationales vous vous êtes contre
il ya quand même des gens monsieur
blanchet qui doivent se dire après avoir
vu tout les cats ont dansé dans ces
maisons pour aînés pendant la première
vague la deuxième vague doit se dire que
peut-être que c'est pas une si mauvaise
idée que ça d'avoir des normes
nationales est-ce que sont
inacceptables que ça on a des normes
nationales ce sont celles de la nation
québécoise dans notre système de santé
la santé est une juridiction du québec
tout le monde tombe un peu dans le piège
le npd totalement pour centraliser les
ottawa c'est une pression irrésistible
de monsieur trudeau même usé ou tout
cela disait moi je transfère sans
conditions mais j'ai un enveloppe que je
réserve j'oblige de soi pour la santé
mentale alors que si tu mets de l'argent
sans payer et envoie l'argent québec
québec au la compétence
constitutionnelle la compétence père et
de gérer système de santé c'est
forcément la proche des plus efficaces
l'approché plus rapide envoyer l'argent
aux gens qui ont la responsabilité et la
capacité de m les politiques et je ne
vois pas je ne vois pas en quoi des
normes fédérales seraient supérieures
meilleur de quelque façon que ce soit à
des normes québécoises je ne connais
rien qu'un canadien soit capable de
faire et qu'un québécois soient
incapables de faire pourquoi faut-il
croire candidement que parce que ça
viendrait du canada ce serait meilleur
que ce qui vient du québec
monsieur blanchet les autochtones pour
proposer l'abolition de la loi sur les
indiens monsieur trou d'où nous faisait
aussi le tout à l'heure vouloir l'abolir
éventuellement cela dit est ce que cette
abolition ne vient pas en contrepartie
d'une chose importante qui doit vous
toucher de très près c'est la concession
de territoire le territoire québécois et
sacré est ce que pour vous c'est aux
gabonais d'avoir serré ça vient
effectivement avec des territoires
concédé au canada comme au québec nous
avons l'obligation en regard de
l'histoire et de nos comportements à
l'endroit des premières nations d'adn
est le fait que nous coexistions survie
même territoire les territoires
revendiqués sur des bases
traditionnelles par les premières
nations sont pas des territoires où ils
disent on veut que les blancs sont nice
et passe à leur rhétorique ces poissons
leur volonté alors allons-y dans la
séquence le canada dit on adhère à la
déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones ça vient
avec des conséquences législatives
nécessaires qui sont pas complétés pour
l'instant saône où on ira après ça il ya
un processus et le chou est assez
d'accord avec le l'information à l'effet
que ça se fait progressivement les
progressivement veut pas toujours dire
lentement bambins lentement ou bine bine
bine lentement il est exact aussi que ça
se fait de nation à nation donc une
nation à la fois ça peut être plusieurs
en parallèle on n'est pas obligé de dire
toi tu es le numéro 43 on peut procéder
il ya peut-être des nations qui vont
vouloir travailler de façon concertée
avoir une voix plus forte à la table
tout cela est tout à fait admissible
mais il faut d'une part que la volonté
soit clair qu'il faut enlever
l'ingrédient paternaliste quand est
arrivée la situation où on en révéler
publiquement parce que comme il l'a dit
lui même le premier ministre savait déjà
qu'ils avaient des sites où était mon
cachet enfouis depuis tellement
longtemps
les restes de jeunes enfants autochtones
notre position était de dire aux nations
autochtones dites nous ce que vous
voulez nous allons le déposer à la
chambre des communes on le fait adopter
de façon unanime il s'agissait de faire
tout s'offre dictée avec un espèce de
prétention de supériorité voici comment
vous allez procéder mais on peut plus
résister on va mettre d'argent là dedans
pour vous dire de faire ça comme ça il
appartient à chacune des communautés
autochtones de faire ses recherches là
et beaucoup ne veulent pas les faire ses
recherches l'ont ils veulent vivre leur
deuil d'une façon différente il faut
respecter ces différents cela est ce que
le territoire québécois doit rester tel
quel est ce que s'il y avait des
négociations avec des communautés
autochtones vous pourriez accepter que
l'on sert des territoires
en contrepartie de l'abolition d'un
personnes banque de sons personne ne
parle de ça ça n'existe pas le canada ne
pourra céder les territoires c'est pas
des partitions territoriales c'est la
coexistence de nations qui sont ici
depuis parfois des dizaines de milliers
d'années et des colonisateurs européens
et de toute l'immigration qui est venu
par la suite qui coexistent sur un même
territoire quels seront les droits
différencier accordés aux uns et aux
autres dans cette coexistence là tout
l'enjeu est là mais il n'y a pas d'enjeu
de partitions de ça ça n'existe pas ce
n'est dans la rhétorique de personnes je
rencontre des nations autochtones
partout sur le territoire il y en a
jamais eu une qui me parle de social
n'existe pas dans leur vision des choses
monsieur blanchet vous souhaitez un
gouvernement minoritaire
la dernière fois en octobre de melgven
une de vos conditions pour appuyer le
gouvernement s'était que le fameux
transferts la facture de la santé 35%
que le fédéral paye 35 % de la facture
ans est ce que la prochaine fois ce sera
la même chose qui soit bleu ou rouge peu
importe vous avez dit est ce que ça sera
votre condition
dur comme fer
d'une part je me permettrai l'occasion
pour rappeler que la demande de toutes
les provinces du québec c'est 35% des
coûts du système de santé plus une
hausse de 6% effectivement ce que
personne ne propose et c'est pourtant la
demande monsieur trudeau ni mesure d'un
propose l'avais je dirais une chose et
son contraire d'une part je ne présume
pas de la composition du prochain
parlement mais la tentation d'en faire
une condition va être très très forte on
est très très très froid ce que parce
que ça fait tellement longtemps que ses
demandes et tout le monde tergiverse les
gens s'imaginent que parce qu'on dit les
mots transferts en santé oms va apaiser
les demandes du gouvernement québécois
alors qu'elle est précise et les
chiffres ips et on sait pas une patente
en gouvernement céder les attentes en
chirurgie c'est des soins paume pour les
gens l'ont dit eux mêmes savent
sélectionnant trois mois monsieur
blanchet même ça veut dire des excuses
moi le gouvernement à négocier comme on
le fait pendant deux ans on aurait pu le
faire pendant 4 1 parce qu'on faisait
des gains ont respecté la volonté des
québécois ont respecté la volonté des
canadiens on a amélioré un grand nombre
de choses une des pires affaire puisse
arriver c'est un gouvernement
majoritaire parce que dans le contexte
actuel majorité ont l'air de
correspondre à une forme d'arrogance de
l'état central un gouvernement
majoritaire qu'il soit bleu ou rouge
comme patrice tente est versé au total
cela dit je reviens quand même et cette
idée qu'un vote pour le bloc ça pourrait
aussi être un vote qui favoriserait le
passage d'un gouvernement conservateur
donc le vote pour le bloc est pas
toujours utile pour certains du kt et
la multiplication des épouvantails en
campagne électorale c'est une pratique
bien connue dont bien sûr on dit parfois
si tu vas pour les libéraux de se passer
des conseils pratiques
mais moi je dis aux gens voter pour ce
que vous voulez voter pour ceux qui
disent que vous avez envie d'entendre
voter selon le temps selon votre cas
selon vos convictions sur votre analyse
la réalité moi pour ma part je sois
libéral ou conservateur si ces
minoritaires je pense qu'on va tirer
notre épingle du jeu ils françois
blanchet merci beaucoup bonne fin de
campagne à vous aussi merci un film
merci des vents sont 27 quand un gars
plaisir